the ascension of aegon targaryen was
confirmed
and the fate of the seven kingdoms
sealed on the field of fire
kings lauren lannister of the rock and
mern gardener of the reach
stood against aegon's invasion they
commanded a united force of
600 banners 5 000 mounted nights and
50 000 men at arms aegon's host was
vastly outnumbered
and when the army of the two kings
charged the invaders turned heel and run
but and almighty was no match for dragon
flame
when aegon unleashed all three of his
dragons
four thousand souls were horrendously
burned alive on the battlefield
king myrn among them realizing all hope
was lost
king lauren surrendered the starks of
winterfell
had no intention of submitting to
targaryen rule
they are drained as kings in the north
since the days of the first men
and were determined to resist the
targaryen invaders
just as they had resisted the andals
thousands of years before
king tauren stark led his army to the
red fork just east of riverrun
hoping to succeed when lauren and mern
had failed
but when tauren saw the size of aegon's
now-mighty host
along with his monstrous dragons he knew
he couldn't subject his followers to the
horror of another field of fire
he bent the knee and swore fealty to
aegon who allowed the starks to maintain
their lordship over the region
as lords paramount and wardens of the
north
without question tauren stark saved
thousands of lives that day
he was ever after known as the king who
knelt
for thousands of years the kingdom of
the rock ruled the westerlands
when the ironborn became a nuisance my
ancestor sailed to the iron islands and
returned with a hundred ironborn
hostages promising to hang one from the
rock every time the ironborn dared radar
shores
the ironborn stayed away well after 20
or so
when the andals arrived after sweeping
across the rest of westeros we invited
their sons and daughters into the rock
as squires and caught ladies
i don't think we ever had to hang any of
them
finally aegon the conqueror defeated us
on the field of fire and my ancestor
knelt
still little changed but titles and
taxes
for when visenya targaryen saw the rock
she gave thanks that my ancestor had met
aegon in the field
even dragonflame would have washed over
the castle like the waves and left just
as much a mark
most of the great houses spout such
nonsense about their origins
at least my family doesn't claim some
long-lost ancient crown like the rest of
them
house tarly breeds soldiers not kings
when house gardner ruled the reach we
served them well
and loyally when house gardener died
an aegon gave the reach to their
stewards the tyrells
we serve them well and loyally
we know our place even if the tyrell
women don't when aegon's son
faced rebellion from the vulture king of
dawn my ancestor
savage samtari led the royal forces on a
vulture hunt
heart spain our ancestral valyrian sword
and the pride of our house
soon ran red from point to hilt with
rebel blood
men have fought over the riverlands
since the dawn age
though that's to be expected of things
arrest below the neck
doesn't help that the riverlands are
between everything and everything
else the westerlands gold the reaches
grain the vale's rock
and the north's snow
house mud once ruled as the kings of the
rivers and hills
but after a thousand years their line
was exhausted and fell to the storm
kings
who fell to the ironborn i suppose after
years of drowning at sea
our rivers looked pretty attractive to
that race of pirates
never mind that their monstrous castle
harrenhal
was too large to staff and garrison it
turned out the ironborn wouldn't be
there long enough to bother
aegon targaryen landed to our south and
as had many before him liked the look of
the riverlands
my ancestor edmund tully led the
desertion of riverlords to his cause
and was rewarded by getting to watch
king harren burn in his own tower
unfortunately that's not all edmund got
house tully was named the lord's
paramount of the trident
which means we had to keep in line all
those lords who hadn't governed
themselves for
thousands of years yet under the
targaryens the riverlands knew a piece
we hadn't had for
centuries if ever
when aegon and his dragons burned haran
the black and all his sons at harrenhal
the days when men feared the sight of
our long ships were over
aegon would not permit marauders and
raiders in his seven kingdoms
with harren died our empire and the old
way that forged it
but what is dead may never die
impregnable
that's how the veil sees itself shielded
from westeros by its mountains
except the veil has been conquered those
vaunted mountains didn't stop the andals
who came by the eastern sea
the people of the vale say that sir
artis aaron the andal general
flew on the back of a giant falcon and
slew the griffin king on top of the
tallest mountain
during aegon's conquest one of his
sisters did the same
flying her dragon over the bloody gate
and up to the eerie
the iron stronghold and the aran boy
king
yielded the veil in return for a ride on
the beast
do you sense the theme here the
rationalizing of defeats with mythical
beasts and the whims of children
instead of acknowledging the root cause
the arrogance of isolation
the first storm king darren started his
reign by declaring war on the gods
themselves
he loved the daughter of the sea god and
the wind goddess but they forbade the
union
at their wedding the gods unleashed
their might pulling down his hold and
killing all of durham's family and
guests
though his wife shielded him darren
vowed to rebuild
and when he did the gods again destroyed
his home
his councillors begged him to retreat
inland but he would not abandon his war
finally with the council of the children
of the forest or perhaps a young brand
the builder
darren raised a seventh castle that
tries they might and still do
the wind and sea gods could not tear
asunder
darren took the name god's grief and
called his new home
storm's end having beaten the waters to
the east
the storm kings turned their gaze to
more practical enemies
the reach riverlands and dawn for
thousands of years the storm kings
fought the gardner-kings of the reach
and various families of dawn
for control of the dornish marches just
below the red mountains
the fighting didn't stop until dawn
married into the seven kingdoms
a mere hundred years ago but still the
houses of the stormlands
such as the dondarians guard the boneway
the mountain pass into the marches
against any dornish incursion the storm
kings had greater luck to their north
at first they took the trident from the
river kings
and built an empire that stretched as
far as the neck
but then the ironborn swarmed out of
their islands and pushed the storm kings
out of the riverlands
no doubt the ironborn intended to expand
their empire into the stormlands
before they had a chance aegon targaryen
landed with his dragons
while aegon burned the kings of the iron
islands the rock and the reach
his fiercest commander and rumored
bastard brother
or his baratheon set out to subdue the
stormlands
no matter how fierce a warrior he was no
one could have embedded his task
storm's end has in thousands of years of
war and never fallen
but argilac the storm king chose not to
barricade himself behind its walls
and gave always the battle he must have
hoped for
oris slewed argilac and took argilac's
castle
kingdom daughter sigil and house words
house baratheon became the lord of the
stormlands
the targaryen dynasty united the seven
kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries
it was a dynasty forged in fire sealed
in blood
and destroyed by rebellion
the targaryens are blood of the dragon
descended from the nobility of ancient
valyria a once mighty empire in the east
when the cataclysmic doom laid waste of
valyria and its people
the targaryens survived having settled
on the island fortress of dragonstone
years before
they remained there for a century until
the rise
of aegon the conqueror instead of
attempting to reclaim the eastern lands
of his ancestors
aegon sailed west for the seven kingdoms
his sisters visenya and rhaenys at his
side
to keep the bloodlines pure aegon
continued the custom of his valyrian
ancestors and took
both of his sisters to wife together
they came ashore on the eastern coast of
westeros
their blazon a dragon with three heads
representing aegon and his sister wives
their words fire and blood
while their host was small in comparison
to the armies of westeros that awaited
them
aegon and his sisters had a secret
weapon
the last of the dragons
he conquered every kingdom save dawn
which eventually bowed to targaryen rule
a century later
he had the swords of his enemies melted
down by the fiery breath of his dragon
valerian the black dread
and forged into the iron throne
the capital city of king's landing was
built on the eastern coast
where aegon and his sisters first came
ashore
and aegon ordered the construction of a
royal castle on its highest hill
the red keep for 300 years the targaryen
dynasty
stayed strong in the face of rebellion
civil war and plague
you